Inbound marketing refers to the
activities that you do and the content
that you create that drives people to
come to you and engage with your site,
your product, or your social channels
rather than having to go out and
get people's attention by ads or
other outbound marketing activities.
You're earning the attention
of your customers and
drawing them in by producing
interesting content.
Then you want to personalize your
content to the needs and wants of your
target audience, and your going to
want to have multi-channel mindset here.
With inbound marketing you're going to
need to connect with your users,
where they are, and where they want
you to connect with them whether
that be by using your blog,
publishing things on social media,
your SEO search results, or
even emails you send out.
Now one thing that's really important
with inbound marketing, and
frankly with all of your marketing
efforts is making sure you're publishing
the right content to the right people
in the right place at the right time.
This intersection will allow your
marketing efforts to be helpful and
relevant rather than annoying and
repetitive.
Let's go to Greg to talk about his
thoughts on inbound marketing.
>> My name's Greg Brauner.
I'm Head of Marketing, at Udacity.
I've been in marketing for
about 15 years.
Inbound marketing is a set
of activities that you take
to engage with your audience to get
them to come to your site directly.
These are things like blog posts, social
posts, things on Facebook, LinkedIn, and
Twitter that you engage
direct with your audience and
get them to come to your site.
So the content attracting
the user to the site is going
to have to be relevant.
So for example in Udacity's case we
provide an education platform and
an education service for
you to come and learn from us.
If we were to post things relating to
education that show us thought leaders
or knowing exactly what we're talking
about in the education space, or
relevant to topics that
they're interested in they're
more likely to come to us.
So being an educational platform when
we send out things that are related to
the continuing education for
them, things that we're
launching that are new,
things that are really relevant to why
they came to use in the first place.
If we start out saying things about cats
and muscle cars it's really not what
they want to hear from us and
they'll ignore us pretty quickly or
wonder what the heck
we're doing over here.
So when you look at creating different
types of content what you really want to
understand is what type of content your
audience really wants to engage with.
There is everything from webcasts
to info-graphics to memes,
but you have to pick the right one for
you and
your audience because they're going
come want to consume in a certain way.
The best way to do that is back
to AB testing is to go ahead and
send out two different messages.
Send out an info-graphic one month and
a meme the next month and
a vine the third month.
See what gets the highest engagement,
and
then from there you can refine
your marketing plan and
determine out what kind of inbound
content you want to spend time on.
So when you look at creating content
you want to make sure you're hitting
the right people with the right content
at the right place at the right time.
Look at Facebook versus Twitter to
get an example of how you engage your
audience differently.
On Facebook you can post
long form content and
engage in a very deep
discussion with your customers.
On Twitter it's a shorter medium right?
So you only have a 140 characters so
you have to really be thoughtful
about what you post, and try and
get them back to your site and
engage with you there.
So when you look at good
quality content and
creating quality content you want
to do it yourself if you can.
You can control the message,
the theme, the colors, the images, and
it's something that really
ties to you and your company.
If you buy content or
syndicate someone else's content you
don't always get what you really want.
I think Virgin America right now is
doing an amazing job with their content
creation and their marketing.
It's unique, it's original,
it's definitely to their brand.
I encourage you to check out their
billboards, and their website.
They've done an amazing job
in creating a fun airline in
a space where it's really
not a lot of fun to fly.
When you look at creating a blog and
a readership there what you really
want to do is have a contact calendar.
Look out a month or two months of what
you want to write, what you want to
talk about, and then figure out
how to get that content created.
So again we're talking
about original content.
What you want to have is
someone creating it for
you in a way that tells your story.
That's the best way to create any
type of sort of blog following.
I would say when you look at publisher
and social you really have to pay
attention to what channels
you want to engage with and
have time to engage with.
When you look at LinkedIn or
Twitter or Facebook,
which are the three kind of big ones
right now they all have their different
ways people want to interact, and
they want to hear back from you as well.
So example on Twitter don't just post
stuff and never go back to it again.
You want to actually engage
because people will retweet you.
They'll talk to you, ask you questions.
Make sure if you do engage in
social you have time to nurture and
engage that community in the way
that they want to talk to you,